hello real rejects my name is Greg Alba
my name is Kat we just did a video where
we talked a lot about sex and apparently
we're keeping the whole relationship
thing going for the next video it's a
theme today dating slang you should know
I'm gonna end this bit now these are
from good mythical morning you know
these guys you might have seen them on
Jimmy Fallon or you just father hugely
popular YouTube channel linked to the
original video in the description box I
want to make that clear right here right
now kal rock comedy on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram is kitten fishing as cute
as it sounds let's talk about that that
sounds like a pedophile thing kitchen
fishing kitten fishing
rhett and Link mythical Morty I know
this may come as a shock to those of you
who consistently drawers as prepubescent
unicorns but we're old we were not born
between the millennial years of 1981 and
1997 oh we have never been to Coachella
don't understand the current Daniel
answer but we are a sea of Millennials
we are we are surrounded by them many of
our crew members regularly swim the
tender sphere it's very liquidy yes
that's they thought that it would be
interesting to well actually we're
talking about some different dating
terms that are in vogue and we don't
even know what in vogue means modern
dating terms if the two of us together
can figure out what they mean and then
we'll be told what the correct kept
condition Oh fun
also see if you know what they mean so
you can express dating superiority over
us okay oh it's an interactive video day
stashing hmm stashing the stack term is
stashing right off the bat I'm thinking
a monster idea so your mom your mustache
is supported well a it's important if we
have it you know I had one for a few
months yeah it was a very important
couple months we did any the most
important of the year did not change my
dating life because I'm married great in
fact it probably would have hurt it does
your wife hated it yeah it hurt my love
life but you know I like it's like the
top shelf it's a hairy it's putting some
hair on the top shelf how does this
translate to dating yes yeah I'm not
following it I think it's not on the
Shelf with you and then when you click
something on the shelf
oh look like another person's lip it's
one no like a person when you put
something on the Sun it means you can
remember it forever
my name is a special place oh you know
you mean setting them aside yeah I think
that's what I think it's summer
that's right you're putting them on the
top shelf
it's like plenty of reverence what types
of forgetfulness which is it are we
correct all right before I find okay I
think I'm not sure I was so caught up in
what I was thinking it was that I
started losing sight of what he was
actually guessing was about mustaches I
don't know after I actually never heard
that but I would imagine stashing means
you collect like multiple girls and you
like you eventually decide who's the one
to get yes yeah flirt with a bunch and
you have them all in like your tinder
thing and then like you go on a coffee
date with a bunch and you guys still
talk to them kind of like stacking yeah
then figure out the one that you want
but you still waste everybody else's
time for gotcha okay oh well no you're
asking Stevie but it's definition verb
I'm right so far great
the act of refusing to introduce the
person you're dating to anyone in your
life you might stash someone if you
don't see a future with them beyond the
church I'm gonna say that that was
correct look it really was incorrect
because it was more like stache like you
hide something away right which I but
it's a weird way you came up with the
same answer okay bread crumbing oh we
know this tell me okay what my guess is
after he canceled you mean yeah and read
the initial this is gotta have something
to do with what bread crumbing
represents which is you're trying to
create a trail and if you're dating
you're trying to create a trail back to
you but you end up in a furnace spoiler
alert person's face so that you can get
back to them so that if they dumped you
they will keep finding pieces of you and
literal could be pieces it could be like
you have a lock of hair or drain and
then your breakup with you and they're
cleaning out there all right I gotta
take this back to read and and get back
together yeah but you can also do things
like this throw a pair of underwear
behind a dresser anything that will call
them to remember you finally person I
don't like you can't a strong their
phone when things when they set it down
and then selfie with yourself and so
great Crum you're putting yourself in
their photos treatment so anyone they
try to get you out of your life they
keep finding your hair and your
underwear and pictures of you on their
phone just to be clear that is so that
you can reconnect yeah okay alright okay
so that's wrong I'll tell you that's not
so good oh it's like that sounds like
bread crumbing okay let me ask you this
in terms of like when you're dating
someone already or your look or your
like date trying to date someone trying
to do try me
during the dating period they're in the
trying to get a girl okay yeah it has to
do something with leaving Clues though
no no okay have you ever had someone who
you were like texting them and talking
to them and then you'll go like a time
period we don't care from them at all a
month even and then you hear back from
them and you talk a little bit but then
they go away for a while hear back from
them like a month later that's the red
coming keeps going for like a year two
years you can be texting somebody and
seeing them like very rarely they're
like almost out of your life then
they'll ping you with a little
breadcrumb gosh pingzhi right in the
head so you don't forget them so it's
kind of like that but just with like
making contact
just enough to stick them in your brain
let's see if you know let's see if you
know let's see if I agree the act of
stringing a partner along without ever
committing to anything serious one might
drop a couple of breadcrumb texts per
week just to keep a potential mate on
the line okay
that isn't nothing that's not what you
say you know hello for
they're sturdier
which obviously relates to gaining an
insulation you're protecting yourself so
even though you're not giving yourself
over fully to the relationship okay
you're not being vulnerable you you're
not being phoner yeah yeah you're
insulating yourself in a pillow just
even your soft parts to a person yes
just your soft parts I know what that
means but not your bloody parts yeah
okay thank you okay what do you think I
got first yes yeah I think that involves
dating multiple people just having a lot
of people on your list really that you
don't you're not alone to like if you
don't have a date have a date on
Saturday or maybe like you don't have a
date early Friday do you have a date
late Friday too in case your early date
on Friday cancels you've got a later
date I don't that's my guess and what
cushioning like you've got cushion
you're not gonna be alone it's oh I
thought cushioning would mean like you
don't really want to commit to someone
but you're you're still like you'd be
sweet to them and stuff that way they
think you're like possibly gonna want to
be with them I feel like you and both of
these guys are like people who are in
relationships a lot and are like very
healthy and sweet nice people and not
people who like me have been in like the
harsh world of singlehood I have only
slept with one and a half people tell me
that wasn't a child oh come on
why'd you go there okay I'm not coming
back on the real rejects anymore that's
your the act of keeping a sidepiece in
one's back pocket as to have a cushion
to fall back on when your psyche you
kind of define a definition come on okay
mooning now I'm certain about this
[Music]
which is showing your your fanny to
somebody for our English friends young
plus you're not supposed to say that
over there but we're here so my
grandma's name is Stan right come on
give me a break
so but this is if you now first of all
you've got to have a nice butt to pull
this off but this is the act of showing
your booty to someone repeatedly as a
lure using a lure yeah so it might be
like if you want to Instagram models
when you do the squats or whatever
that's a good way but you set up some
sort of scene where they have like a
plumbing issue and you literate like you
loosen some things and not in the body
and their house and then you literally
go there and perform some plumbing
exercises reveal the booty like a little
bit of cleavage and they will be enticed
so this one works well if you're a
plumber yes where do I mean is it
something about me showing your butt
right I'm dating term I think we're
getting too old yeah I mean that's I
think that's what moaning okay let's
play definition verb putting the Do Not
Disturb on a text message chat in order
to efficiently ignore them yes
oh I have known many people oh the moon
symbol yeah oh I tried to do that on a
group text once and instead I push the
button and share my located - catfishing
no I'm gonna go no definitely not
we hear this one in a millennial context
like a sentence oh my god I met up with
Asher from bumble at Starbucks so we
could try and donut waffle rainbow
Frappuccino and who totally kiddin
fished me he doesn't have a man but he
just clipped a ball of extensions to it
so he showed up but his hair was fake
yeah well catfishing is so this is like
little catfish I don't know what camp
fishiness catfishing is when you
misrepresent yourself fishing is a small
way like the man bonding okay Ferb this
is the less extreme version of
catfishing yeah I got it yeah oh you do
it by text active presenting 70 men
attractive light on the Internet the
following obviously short in person as
in literally short most men kitten fish
about their height on tinder or they're
fake man bun you know anything about
that
yeah I know what about that um friend um
friend with an in um friend to me this
again this is sort of like you got a
look at the root words this is when
you're dating someone and you find out
there turn to the last second can't turn
if you're an umpire yeah okay okay
here's my guess it's when it's when you
meet like when you're like you're with
somebody and then you got someone's like
oh is this your boyfriend and you're
like he's my um friend oh that is great
that is great there's no it has to be
yeah you're right alright yeah I I agree
this is a noun or verb to turn when a
romantic interest isn't quite a
boyfriend/girlfriend partner or on fire
or getting butt awkwardly referred to as
an um French okay so Sam we're the
middle ground where you don't know where
you stand you're an unfriend
okay that makes a little bit more sense
but that umpire story was completely
real
we now have a relatively undiscovered
video and have you comment on it we're
sending over to facing my bird fears
well she'd a comment telling her how
brave she is listen
sincerely be mythical don't tell him we
sent you and don't be mean subscribe to
them man I love these guys they're so
funny I close to stashing we were pretty
close on bread crumbing you knew I've
been bread crumb that was close to home
what's cushioning again that's for you
you have a girlfriend but you have
another girl she's not quite a side
piece but you like keep talking to her
in case like a back burner and what's
moving Moony that's when you like put
someone on yeah yeah right okay smart on
friend oh great great guest thank you
that was really that was brilliant
absolutely brilliant well good I feel
like I learned so I did I feel like I
learned hey subscribe to good mythical
morning to be a but there were a hugely
popular chatter I'm sorry further than
fear oh damn there's so much slaying out
there I don't know what happening just
meeting people and like you someone they
don't do that why nobody wants to be
loved we all just want to do it with
strangers on team not me I've never
hooked up with a girl ons on tinder good
for you bro never I don't know if you
sincere or not I never have good job
that
mean I never tried alright guys follow
me
below the cat Alvarado comedy on
Facebook oh just cat Alvarado comedy on
face I mean yeah cat Alvarado on Twitter
and Instagram subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe to good mythical
morning so click that notification bell
become a patron eject today I go into
patreon.com slash the Rio region